look at kids in social media studies
show that too much time on social media
apps can be linked to anxiety and
depression on average american children
ages 8 to 12 spend four to six hours a
day watching or using screens and for
teens it's up to nine hours a day i sit
down with my 11 year old daughter mia
for honest conversation about her social
media use i wanted to find out which app
she uses the most and how they make her
feel take a look
let's say out of 10 friends how many of
them do you think have
an instagram account or a tick tock
account
all of them
now do you use facebook
no
that's for grandmas
okay
your mom uses facebook she's not a
grandma
okay
do you use instagram no
i have an account but i don't use it
okay
now do you use tick-tock yes how often
um do you want the truth yeah
um about
more than eight hours a day probably
eight hours a day yeah
and what do you use it for
um
i usually just scroll on tick-tock and
watch videos
when you're on tick-tock
do you feel
smarter
not smarter kind of just like
more free i feel like when i'm on tick
tock i can like relate to things better
you know sometimes when you're on social
media
i wouldn't say it's like an addiction
but
it'll be something that like brings you
joy
but then when you don't find anything on
it you'll still want to look for things
that'll make you happy i feel like at
one point you were addicted to tick-tock
yeah
do you think you were
definitely there's no doubt
so let me ask you this
do you like the color of your skin
do you like the way you look yes
do you get positive reinforcement in
this house what are some of the things
that your mom and i say to you
um you remind me that my skin is
beautiful that
when i'm going out for dinner or
something and i dress up that i look
beautiful
are there times when you're on social
media
and
maybe you don't like the way you look or
you
question how beautiful you are
i find something that's like really
pretty i'm like oh my gosh they're so
pretty
and then um i'll look at myself and i'll
be like oh i wish i looked like them or
something
but then don't you turn around and think
to yourself
i'm also pretty
yeah
i'm like oh i'm pretty anyway it doesn't
matter
what would you say to kids
who are on social media and because they
don't measure up to somebody else's
standards
their lifestyle
or the way they
look they feel sad so
um recently
i on the first day of school i tried to
dress my best because i wanted to make a
good impression you're in a new school
yeah
but then i realized like all the other
most of the other kids they don't care
and i have lots of respect for people
who just don't care because
as long as they don't care they seem
happy because at the end of the day you
might as well live your life
with the as happy as you can be
and just enjoy every second of it
without trying to compare yourself
or anything
mia you are the coolest
i know
the smartest and the most beautiful
we are joined by jamie howard senior
clinical psychologist at the child mind
institute good morning thank you so much
for joining us before we talk to you
jamie can we just have a minute just to
talk about that interview number one i
became i got a girl crush on mia when i
saw the two of you interview michelle
obama back in the day i thought she is
so poised and so smart but i love the
dynamic between the two of you you
didn't wince when she said she was on
tick-tock for eight hours do you all
have house rules we do i was surprised
that you just said okay if you have
straight a's and you're doing your
chores um and you're a good student then
you can be on tick-tock you can be on
any app you want and also play video
games but as soon as you do something
wrong you lose those privileges but
there was a moment there where i
realized how much she hears us give her
positive reinforcement yes but when she
answered the question and she said
sometimes i see another girl who's
pretty and i don't feel as pretty
my heart started to drop right and i
almost got choked up i had to collect
myself because in that moment i realized
no matter
how much reinforcement she gets yes i'm
fighting against
an unseen enemy which are people on the
other side of the screen that are
putting videos out there and she's
reading these comments that people are
posting jamie i want to start with you
um
as a parent
what can we do because we are also
filled with anxiety
so you did a lot of great things it
sounds like you give your daughter lots
of positive reinforcement lots of
specific labeled praise you value other
things besides how she appears so she
has to do well in school so that's what
parents can really do we want to
encourage our kids to get in real life
kind of social experiences with all the
non-verbals that you get from like a
real life conversation engage in hobbies
move your bodies get good sleep because
a lot of kids who have this kind of
quote unquote addiction they they're
watching their their abs all night
they're not getting good sleep and that
really affects us and it can be linked
to increased rates of depression as good
as it is social media does seem to be a
double-edged sword to me how do we
navigate that dance jamie so i don't
think we want to say that you can't be
on social media at all right because
that would be socially really
disadvantageous to your kids but we want
to have limits and unrealistic and
unrealistic right and we so we want to
have limits sometimes we'll say about
two hours as long as you're doing things
like your homework and you're doing
things in real life you're engaged in
other activities and you want to model
good behavior as parents so put your
phones down put your phones down during
meals have a place where you can put
your phone so that everyone knows like
right now it's screen free time and you
can just put the phone face down because
adolescents hate it when they think
maybe a parent or someone could see
something pop up yeah so you say about
two hours of screen time i'm hearing
about eight hours in that interview nate
i had no idea
it was eye opening for me um and i
realized the moments where she is on the
phone she hurry up and gets her homework
done we check her grades and she
realizes i have a ton of time on my
hands yeah and living with two older
brothers that are teenagers she's like
i'd rather hang out with my girls on
social media because it's a it's a
experience where it's a collective about
five kids doing the same thing on a
social media app right which was so
helpful during the pandemic too so kids
could stay connected it's just the flip
side is the social comparison
it's very hard for parents to try to
police the hours almost impossible with
my 12 year old facebook uh which owns
instagram facebook is for grandma she's
for grandmas
ouch yikes
instagram also no it was a non-starter
for her i thought that was interesting
uh instagram is uh going to introduce a
feature where teens can take a break
from the app the details are yet to be
determined but could that help i think
that could help having some sort of
responsibility that we impose on kids
that we sort of model for them let's do
this let's take a little break so that
you don't get so sucked in right it's
not technically an addiction because
it's not a foreign chemical but it's so
what we call reinforcing that once
you're in it is so hard to get out yeah
not just for kids for adults for adults
too yeah jamie howard thank you so much
we appreciate you